breaking tonight secretary of state tony
blinken saying he is deeply disappointed
and taking the extraordinary step
of directly calling out a specific state
california
for its impending parole of convicted
assassin harry sasunian
lincoln says quote it has been the
long-standing position of the united
states
to advocate that those who assassinate
diplomats
receive the maximum sentence possible
and that they serve those sentences
without parole or
early release cesunian was convicted of
the 1982 murder of the turkish consul
general
to los angeles as the crisis on the
southern border continues to worsen the
blame
game is underway breaking tonight
mexico's president is blaming the
biden administration for the massive
influx of illegal immigration into the
u.s
chief breaking news correspondent trace
gallagher has the story for us tonight
good evening trace
shannon good evening let's begin with
the numbers in february of this year
there were more than a hundred thousand
apprehensions on the u.s mexico border
that's 174 percent
increase from last february and overall
those are the worst numbers since 2019.
the number of unaccompanied minors is
also at record levels where children are
being held
longer than the 72-hour maximum but
apparently the outrage over kids in
cages faded when president trump left
office
and remember all of these people got to
the u.s through mexico which
is the reason mexican president andres
manuel lopez obrador said
this about president biden quoting they
see him as the migrant president
and so many feel they're going to reach
the united states
and they feel that way because they
believe the us is not only welcoming
migration but
incentivizing it for example here's
fox's griff jenkins where construction
was stopped
at former president trump's border wall
and experts say
there is a perception that the wall has
stopped and now the door
is open certainly the gangs and cartels
that specialize in human smuggling
are working every angle one mexican
official told
reuters that organized crime began
changing its modus operandi
quote from the day biden took office
that mo
includes briefing migrants on
immigration rules
using technology to evade u.s
authorities
even disguising smuggling operations as
travel agencies even biden advisor
acknowledges
the administration policy may have
driven the surge
watch the idea that a more humane policy
would be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
but perhaps more importantly it
definitely drove smugglers
to express
disinformation to spread disinformation
about what was now possible
she also later said in spanish quote the
border
is not open could have fooled several
hundred border patrol agents
who have now been overwhelmed for more
than a month
and it's worth noting that peak
migration season
doesn't really kick in until april
or mid-may shannon